[Music]
as a matter of metaphysical reality we
live in a deterministic universe free
will is free will for a purpose you're
you're doing something because it means
something not just because it's a random
choice what are we ever trying to do but
trying to get what's true um we don't we
wouldn't want to be free not free to go
whichever way we want we want to go to
the truth the second thing is that
people over overestimate the extent to
which a free choice has to be a
conscious choice so these psychology
[Music]
you do what you do because of the way
you are
in any given situation okay so to be
ultimately responsible for what you do
you have to be ultimately responsible
for how you are
promised too
premise three well but you can't be
ultimately responsible for the way you
are because you'd have to be alright
there already to kind of set yourself up
and that would lead to an infinite
regress
so you can't be ultimately responsible
for what you do
that's the argument um and why doesn't
it have an impact on how we
run things in society how we might run
our criminal justice system yeah um i
think there are sort of actually there's
three answers i want to give one is my
dad's answer a famous paper called
freedom and resentment by pf strawson
where he says
you know it's just not a real question
for us because our we're emotionally
tuned in such a way that we can't not
treat other people as free and feel
guilty ourselves
my answer is different because i think
he thinks the true
the true ground of the inability to give
up belief in free will is our attitudes
to others i think it's our own
experience of free will
and this on the side on the societal
matter
i think i had a people called sault
smilansky and i think he gives a good
answer which is
uh really it's a necessary illusion in a
way um
for some
simple reasons and some very complicated
reasons which we could
go into i mean one of the things is we
can't help believing we are free and it
would be it would be a tremendous
affront to our self-image and our
self-conception
if we were treated as if we had it
hadn't got it
i better perhaps now also give you the
little toy story about why we can't help
believing it okay
i'm afraid i've not been very
imaginative i've had a story i tell for
ages but i'm going to tell it again
so um it's the evening of a national
holiday you've got you know it's a feast
you've got a spread
but you think really nice to have one
more cake on the table and everyone
comes tomorrow so you go to the shop
and you've got 10 pounds
and the shop's about to close
and there's one cake left in the shop
and it cost 10 pounds
and on the on the step of the shop is a
person collecting money for oxfam
for a charity
and you stand there and
existentially pragmatically
you cannot not feel yourself to be
absolutely radically free
to choose which thing to do
even if you know even if you believe
determinism is true and you believe and
that five minutes later you can turn
back round and say well what i did was
determined in that moment you are
radically existentially free that's
that's my argument that's why i think
it's
primarily grounded in first person
experience not in social matters
[Music]
it seems to me that the question
um
are human beings free or not
is the wrong question
and a dangerous question because if we
ask ourselves about the ways in which
human beings all human beings are
caught in a deterministic universe
inevitably
that
focuses our attention away from the
really crucial ways in which some human
beings are more free than others so
philosophers have long thought that just
as a matter of metaphysical reality we
live in a deterministic universe thomas
hobbs in the 17th century david hume in
the 18th century thought that every
action that human beings perform comes
about as a result of a chain of cause
and effect that's just the world that's
the metaphysical reality about the world
that we live in when i am confronted
with a choice between a stick of celery
and a piece of chocolate however much i
think i might have wanted to choose the
celery in the in the end i choose the
chocolate um you know i think as i'm
going out for an evening that i'm not
going to drink and then i get someone
hands me glass wine i think all right
and there's this way in which my actions
are determined
um
you know another sort of deeper kind of
psychoanalytic way of thinking about it
would be that um i used to think a lot
about freedom and the way in which i was
making choices but it just turns out as
a matter of fact that i've ended up
doing broadly the same job as my mother
so there's a kind of so this is
deterministic metaphysical reality but
what david hume pointed out
is that
sure
the world is the universe is governed by
determinism
but that has no bearing
on our phenomenological experience of
the world which is that of freedom
we feel as though we are free we we um
we experience freedom and it's that
lived reality which i think we need to
concentrate on partly because as paul
has suggested um without the belief in
freedom
we lose all sense of responsibility
so if it's if it's um not the case that
i'm free not to murder if i'm not free
not to lie then it would make no sense
to blame me for doing those things and
the entirety of society becomes
unintelligible unless we take it for
granted that there is such a thing as
freedom and the responsibility that goes
alongside that
and secondly the reason why i think we
have to think about the freedom as it is
experienced is because we all know
the difference between
a life
that feels free
and a life that is impeded in various
ways we are sitting here in hampstead
free to talk about freedom
when there are people in this country
who are locked in rooms being forced to
have sex
there is a there is a very distinct um
there are many crucial distinctions uh
between the experience of freedom and
different people's lives and it's that
um that sharp end if you like of the
lived experience of freedom or unfreedom
that we need to take account of a woman
is unfree
if she does not have access to
legal safe free abortion and of course
there the ambiguity of the word free is
very instructive because it indicates
the ways in which our freedom as human
beings is deeply dependent on our
economic circumstances
so there's very basic ways in which
money
gives you freedom in some countries if
you don't actually have money you don't
have the freedom to live because you
can't afford health care
so i think that we have to take account
we don't we no way
you know screw the metaphysics
and um and let's focus on our lived
reality which is that we know the
difference between a free and a less
free life and it's our responsibility
as free agents to try to give people as
much control over their lives as
possible
[Music]
well i've always been troubled by free
will one or the other and there are
experiments people do which show
that some part of them you try to make a
conscious choice about something
and there's some evidence of a build up
of signals which tells you that some
parts of the brain knew which choice you
were going to make
but all these things are
not what you'd use free will for you
it's not quite
particularly because i had experiences
when i was young you said let me give
you this
my younger brother used to there's this
game scissors and paper stone you know
that way
and there are three things you do either
the scissors or the paper or the stone
and you and you don't reveal it until
the last minute
and he used to wallop me at this game
consistently and i thought i was using
free will you see to decide which i'm
going to do
how does he know you know is it some
mystery predicting the future or
something so what i did is i went to a
table of logarithms and i just worked it
out you know
seven means stone eight means scissors
or whatever it was and all the way
through you see so i take these digits
and i would
play this game reading off the digits
and then i broke even
so it was as though
my free will was not really much of a
free will you see i was just
doing what sort of came easily to me at
the moment
and that kind of thing um okay maybe you
can
make predictions about what people are
going to guess next
and it's not really a
free will is free will for a purpose
you're you're
doing something because it means
something not just because it's a random
choice
but i i don't know i've always been in
two minds about that and you see physics
you might think well it's all determined
and so
what you do now is determined by what
happened yesterday or if you knew all
the details of how all particles were
moving but this isn't quite true as
things go because you have this curious
thing
within quantum mechanics
you have the collapse of the wave
function that the schrodinger equation
chugs along and says what's going to
happen suddenly it doesn't it's
something
it jumps to this or that
and people usually talk this and talk
about this in terms of measurements
but my view is that it's happening all
the time and you have just lots of
particles and when they get up to a
certain mass level then it does one
thing or another
and whenever those choices are made
you see stuart hameroff and i have built
up this idea about consciousness
and we consider that
consciousness comes about
when these collapse wave function
things happen now the question is does
it collapse
in a way which is
random that's the that's the way physics
works now you consider it to be quite
random
or if it's maybe entangled with all
sorts of other things and that the
decision about what it makes this or
that has some kind of
content to it some mental content
which is not altogether random and that
would be
where the free will plays its role
so
you know maybe that's controlled by some
deterministic laws which go deeper than
the laws we know now
or is there some actual freedom
in what happens in the in the operation
of the universe i'm not making any
sitting on one side or the other here it
just seems to be quite appealing that
there is something in a choice
which is
not actually determined by the other
laws of physics
and it's it's something more much more
subtle than
than being random it would have to be
something which has a
goes beyond computation and that's what
i claim is is involved when we make
conscious choices
but whether it's how free it is i don't
know i wouldn't like to make a strong
claim on that but there's room there's
room for some kind of a
thing that you might call free will
there yes
[Music]
behind what philosophers call an
incompatibilist that's to say i am
someone who thinks that free will is
incompatible
um
with determinism the thesis that
philosophers call determinism that's to
say the idea that everything that
happens is determined by uh
so i
i do have a different position from uh
from both dan and and patrick i think
dan is a compatibleist for example
um
where i share
their view is in thinking that uh free
will even
on an incompatible misconception of it
such as i have
doesn't have to be mysterious or in
conflict with science or anything like
that and the way i think about
the power of free will which i actually
give a different name to i call it
agency because
i think the
term free will tends to
suggest that free will has to be a
rather highfaluting thing which could
not be had by simpler
agents such as animals
whereas the perspective i want to bring
to the free will debate is to say well
look might it be
that our nature as animals is what
provides the the core um
resources that we need in order to have
indeterministic free will that's what i
believe is the case that animals are
really rather special creatures with
special um biological powers not
mysterious powers you know their powers
that we can come to understand
um and they do indeed arrive from
derived from aspects of our materiality
of course they don't come from nowhere
they're not god given that you know
we don't have to buy any of this in
order to think that incompatibilism
might be true and that um
the world is not deterministic in part
because of the existence of creatures
like animals which do have the capacity
as i put it to settle things that's to
say to make the world go one way when it
really could have gone another really
could have gone another um not just
could have gone another in some you know
relative
way so that i i do think i disagree both
probably certainly with dan
and probably also with patrick in
thinking that indeterminism is a
necessary condition for the free will
but i don't worry about that because i
think the world is indeterministic and
there's but there's always no doubt at
all that it is
[Music]
the kind of free will that the law and
that our everyday folk understanding and
morality presupposes um is is a
compatibilist
notion we do say could have done
otherwise but what we mean by that is
not
something metaphysical but something
very practical
we don't hold very small children
uh morally responsible because in an
important sense they couldn't have done
otherwise about things that they will
soon be able to do otherwise because
they will have acquired the capacity to
reflect and anticipate and and assess
the likely effects of their actions and
will choose if if they're you know well
well raised and and are are
have a good heart and those solid
citizens they'll choose a course which
which doesn't cause great harm because
they can
now this this is the this is the could
have done otherwise of control theory
has nothing to do with quantum
indeterminism
um if you
take two
one of my favorite examples take two
chess playing computers they're both
let's say entirely deterministic but
they make use of pseudo-random numbers
and if you put two chess playing
computers to playing chess against each
other
um
thousands of games
like a deep mind
go program
one one program will win most of the
time maybe all the time
why did it win
because it makes better choices
you have to go to that higher level to
see it's not something in the
fine-grained molecular structure of the
programs it could be identical they
could be running on the same hardware
it's
the fact that one of them
makes wiser choices because it makes
better use of information
now
children
growing up
grow into free will they don't have
morally
relevant free will when they're born
free will is something you grow into and
as helen says
forget about magical moments when you
shazam you suddenly have free will
it's
it's something
that we grow into it's a competence it's
a set of competences that gradually
accrue
and we have sometimes special ceremonies
where we say you're now an adult you now
have the rights and responsibilities of
a responsible adult and most people make
the grade
and there's nothing
magical there's nothing even
metaphysical about it
determinism is simply irrelevant
to the question of whether or not that
process occurs it obviously does occur
in this world and
that's why when
some people writing about free will
they're always trotting out cases of
people with brain tumors who go killing
people or something like that well yes
of course those people don't have free
will because they don't have the
competences because they have an
explicable
defect
they can't do otherwise because they're
not wired right for doing otherwise but
that doesn't mean you can't be wired
right most people are wired right
[Music]
uh if the universe is not predetermined
we live in a determined universe with
cause and effect but not predetermined
then the outcome is not predictable in
not even in principle
not even laplace's demon that knows
every particle and every motion and so
forth to predict what is it what does
that mean
can you just clarify what you mean again
in principle there's a quantum
mechanical calculation that won't
predict what will happen but we'll
predict the probability of what will
happen and then as sabina mentioned
there is this issue of the quantum
measurement problem that is unresolved i
agree with what's being said completely
that's the missing piece but if we put
that to the side just for having this
conversation
i would say that the probabilities are
in principle determined
by
the collection of particles that are
engaged in whatever macroscopic system
you're talking about
interesting yeah so this kind of touches
on almost the free will determinism
problem oh see here again
from free will yeah doesn't exist
so if you just take like opioid
addiction you could drill down to the
molecular level of synaptic
transmissions of of
you know neural chemical transmitter
substances and how they're affected by
uh
cocaine or whatever
and then from there scale up but at some
point it seems to me that the system is
so complex and the person himself or
herself is an active agent within the
causal net of the universe and at some
point just decides i'm gonna do i'm
gonna go left instead of right i'm gonna
i'm gonna you know control my addiction
or i'm not and we know some people can
do this and some can't so it's not that
it's determined
in the future that we already know
exactly if we knew every particle which
which every every person that would be
an addict and which or not
that in fact there's an element of
volition in there of knowing what the
causal vectors are and what you could do
to control the forthcoming your future
self and and kind of predetermining your
own future self by taking some control
over those variables here it's a kind of
a semantic game maybe but that's what
you mean by bullets
but i just wouldn't confuse
predictability in the sense of being
able to do the calculation
with
some kind of volition which to me is a
ghost in the machine
if it's not the particles and laws of
physics if you're saying there's
something else you got to tell me what
that something else is and i know you
well enough to know that you don't think
there's anything else no no of course
not
[Music]
i think i think the part of the problem
is that when people say there's a
scientific determinism it means
everything is cause and effect there are
certain conclusions people draw from
that which simply don't follow one is
that therefore there's no such thing as
choice well okay that's not true people
make choices the question is you know
what's governing those choices if i if
you go to the coffee shop now you will
choose one thing or another so the
question is simply what's underlying
that and i think the other problem which
is really important is that there are
different sort of levels of organization
of matter and it's kind of like
ridiculous to think that if we accept a
deterministic universe then it means
that the only evidence makes sense to
talk about cause and effect at some like
the subatomic level that's not true now
i mean and actually not even a lot of
the people who deny free will say that
people say oh it's going on in your
brain your brain is not fundamental
physics it's an organization a matter of
a higher level of organization now it
seems to me that the reason we can have
this sort of compatibilism is that the
the the fact that the universe is of
course leaders let's tell you what
compatibilism is okay so this is the
view that we can accept the fact
good question you accept the fact that
everything happens is a result of laws
of cause and effect but the point is
that
that it doesn't mean that the only
genuine explanations of what happened to
what happens at the most fundamental
level of physics if you smash a car into
a wall the smashing of the carpet will
cause both things to destruct that is
true and in no way contradicts what we
know about science we're simply
describing it at a certain level and in
the same kind of way i make choices i
make decisions i have regrets etc etc
none of these things are just inherently
incompatible with a deterministic
universe and and once you see that then
the questions about what problems there
are from free will become much much more
subtle and more interesting than we have
to either accept the deterministic view
or give up on freedom i it does seem to
be that frustrating once you've
explained it all it seems some people
are satisfied that
what i'd say is free will is good enough
for free will others don't it is it's
very difficult actually
like what's difficult
nowhere
what what what is funny is what makes me
excited it's difficult what makes people
settle on one side or another seems to
be not quite determined by the arguments
there seems to be always something
temperamental about it some people are
temperamentally inclined to go one way
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv